hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about healthy
lifestyle hacks part one these are
things that you can use in other people
your family yourself to implement
changes in your lifestyle and the first
principle is that you must make tiny
changes small doable steps action steps
that anyone can do and that way if you
make it easy enough you'll be able to do
it without any pain or you know being
uncomfortable okay so here are some
things that you can do number one and
you can pick any of these and even
implement one per week if you need to
but if we do it if we make it easy then
you can actually confront and start it
okay so number one add a kale shake into
the diet every single day why because
you can drink your greens it's very easy
take kale take some berries water blend
it up I have a lot of recipes on this
and then you just drink this every day
this is going to get not just any type
of vegetable but the highest level
nutrient type stuff in your body be very
important to do this this would be very
very easy to do as well just blend it to
drink it take it to work you know simple
or you know maybe you just focus on one
huge salad per day some people don't
even have one cup you know a vegetable
per day so we want to make sure this is
a beefy salad but this would be very
important I have actually two huge
salads every single day but if you just
get one like at least five cups
you're almost there with your potassium
level so just took one sailor today it's
a no-brainer so it's easy to implement
then we have one apple cider vinegar
drink okay here's the brand right here
organic apple cider vinegar take one
tablespoon per glass of water okay and
you drink that at least one a day it'd
be best if you drink this with each meal
but let me tell you why that's important
apple cider vinegar has unique
properties in acidifying the body I know
people say that everyone's to acid we
need to alkalize the body but honestly I
found just the reverse most people are
actually too alkaline we need to certify
the body especially if you're under
stress when you're under stress the body
becomes too alkaline
yes your urine will be
but the blood is overly alkaline okay
now outside of vinegar will acidify the
body allow you to digest better Poland
minerals but really the other benefit is
that it helps stabilize blood sugars it
actually decreased the need for insulin
it's great for insulin resistance so
it's going to help you go longer without
eating it's going to help your blood
sugars it's just an it's a really good
thing to implement okay next one healthy
fats why well number one we want to add
fat with a meal to go longer without
eating because every time you eat you
spike insulin so if we don't have the
fat you're going to be hungry you're not
going to be satisfied after you eat okay
so what's a healthy fat what about an
avocado you can do an avocado when you
eat okay so this is a healthy fat these
are healthy fats you can do P cons
Stassi owes you know you can do these
fats it's no brainer just prepare it and
make sure every meal you add a healthy
fat olives is a good one peanut butter
things like that so if you add the fats
it allows you to go longer without
eating and don't worry about calories
worry about what the calories do to your
body we want to keep insulin down that's
the hormone that makes people fat that's
the thing that creates diabetes by doing
that we need don't want to eat six meals
a day we want to have two or three meals
but add the fat to go longer okay next
one no snacking see if you just picked
one of these and kept implementing it
maybe every few days or every week
eventually you're going to get there so
you want to go at your own pace but this
one is a very important one if you just
cut out the snacking the grazing at
night the snacking at night or snacking
between meals you would lose some weight
almost as important as what you eat with
the meals so if even if you ate some
sweet with a meal and you didn't snack
you probably lose weight okay that's how
powerful in a minute fasting is if not
eating between meals very very important
this would be a good thing too
implement in your body so now the next
one is stop going out to eat why because
you can't trust the restaurants there
are so many other chemicals in
restaurants they have hidden msg people
go to restaurants too much you don't
know what you're getting you're going to
get bloated they give you the wrong
portion size they give you all this food
they always bring the bread it's very
tempting very social you drink the
alcohol not a good thing if you're
trying to lose weight or get healthy so
if you just maybe didn't go to eat for a
while or went out to eat less that will
be one change that you can make next one
no fruit if you were just to cut up
fruit and hidden sugars and that would
be also like cut out breads pasta cereal
crackers or sugars and you didn't change
anything else that probably would
produce a huge benefit to your weight
weight loss and then how about this one
no alcohol some people cannot give this
up so what I'm going to recommend is cut
it down drink less and don't drink is
frequent why because every time you
drink even like a glass of alcohol
you're going to create some liver damage
and you're pretty much setting yourself
back for two to three days so if you're
drinking every other day that's going to
be a problem so let's see you drink once
a week and don't spread it out on the
weekend just like once get it over with
let your liver heal you know or cut it
out completely so you pick the ones that
you can do comfortably and then you keep
implementing these each you know a few
days or every week at your own pace okay
so that is hack part one now let's go to
part two